ecuadorans are struggling with an
unprecedented economic crisis
the question for many is who to blame
their current centrist president lenin
moreno
or his socialist predecessor rafael
correa
that may be the key to sunday's
presidential elections
like the current president taxi driver
emiliano pibake is confined to a
wheelchair
he backed mourinho in the last election
hoping the poor would get
a better break but things have gone from
bad to worse
since the government implemented
dramatic belt tightening measures
imposed by the imf now pibake plans to
vote for the return of left-wing
populism
because they say that correa stole and
many other things but in fact he did
lots of public works projects while the
current government hasn't done
anything except persecute opponents
there's 16 official presidential
candidates
but the most significant one isn't even
on the ballot
at least not in person
instead 35 year old economist andres
arraus
is representing his former boss rafael
correa
who is living in belgium where he moved
before an ecuadorean court
sentenced him to eight years in prison
on corruption charges
araus is leading in the polls promising
to bring back the days of heavy social
spending
while campaigning with photos of his
mentor correa says there'd be no
question about the election outcome
if he'd been allowed to run
if i'd been a candidate there's no doubt
we'd win by a landslide they destroyed
the country
persecuted me and my allies and
slandered us
i had to return to politics and defend
our legacy our honor and the country
it's that prospect that frightens people
like luis herrera
his car parts business went from boom to
bust under correa
he hopes ecuadorans will vote for
centrist banker and businessman
guillermo lasso of the creating
opportunities party made the mistake of
giving korea too much power
and he did what he pleased as though he
owned the country he didn't take
advantage of the years of bonanza when
oil prices were sky high
they stole all the money
while trailing a third place in the
polls ecologist
jacob perez is offering a middle ground
between populist socialism and a
mainstream free market economy
but whoever wins will have more than the
economy to deal with
according to a recent poll when
ecuadorians were asked where they
thought the country would be in five
years
eighty percent answered the same or
worse than now that shows that
governability may be the key problem
and unless that perception can be
reversed through elections
many warn it may be the preamble to
social upheaval
far more widespread than what ecuador
has already experienced
to see a newman al jazeera